[Music]
in bujji divorce news submitted by
millions of dollars I'm gonna find out
on the ground somewhere heavy doe books
they really submitted it I wish I had
millions of dollars in the 1930s that'd
be like billions now yeah yeah go back
to your country
couples are checking into the divorce
hotel to check out of their marriages
there's a divorce or two there is a
divorce hotel so would you sleep this in
New York this sounds like a boy awesome
Saratoga Springs New York why do I feel
like New York is one of those places
where they have a hundred percent rate
of divorce life so hard yeah I feel like
that Wall Street you got to work 80
hours a week lifestyle yeah I picture
like like this super hard-working power
couple that never have time for each
other and then they like always argue
when they get home will they cheat on
each other with you in the airplanes Oh
Oh like stepbrothers I'm gonna say up in
the air with George Clooney but that was
okay well I just Google divorce rate in
New York and in 2015 95 percent it was
100 percent you were right no I said it
was 2.7 divorce rate per thousand
inhabitants that 22.7% yeah that's
really great percentage straight I mean
is that does that equal 2.7 percent in
general or does it know you have to do
math did it I mean we're all looking
this up under whatever Joe just said
about it being 100 percent that's like
one point three five out of five hundred
right okay point seven is not
please my header it's I don't math I
just feel like a lot of people divorce
in New York okay that's why this
business is there or else what about
actually it started in the Netherlands
they divorce a lot over there I did beat
a divorce over there why yeah I felt
that they didn't even marry in the
Netherlands because they're so equal
about everything yeah well they this
whole thing started there and we have
partners and so now they're offering
this package well they've been offering
this package it's 2014 but we're talking
about it now so they have offered this
package in this one particular hotel
it's called Gideon's Putnam Resort & Spa
Hotel spa Gideon's who remembers that
guy that's a local la thing yeah crazy
Gideon's I'm crazy these deals anyway
$200 TV no $100 which smashes [ __ ] he
would see the dollar calculator I'm
crazy parodied in like TV shows I think
that a lot of guys were like that we pay
JK um he was he would come out in a
straitjacket there'll be two of girls in
like a bikini like that he got from the
strip club or something that's a
reversible inner self yeah he was there
were 95 crazy I met him actually he owns
a lot of warehouses and spaces and did
you get his autograph no but who you
were they his son turned his businesses
into film locations the kind of films I
don't know know
all right anyway so I'm going to show
you guys this clip of the divorced hotel
and this couple that recently stayed
there so in three days you're guaranteed
to walk out divorced and that's civil
yeah and like while you're doing that
you have a mediator and if things get
heated up then one person goes and gets
a massage and the other person goes and
plays golf and then they cool down and
then they come back down those are all
[ __ ] original stereotypes [ __ ]
don't you have a boxing ring
the package is five thousand dollars by
the way here we go I can't be married in
this guy anymore
Stevie's like an insurance executive who
works crazy hours after 15 years
together
they've had enough but the end the day
we can be friends at after it's all over
combinations in their own way of course
they also got a professional mediator
Michelle Martin you come here you know
how long it's going to take you know how
much it's going to cost a career in
their marriage
the mood is cordial Blake and Stevie
divvy up their financial assets but the
gloves come off on the issue of child
where I never have a full week ever
Scott the mediator calls a timeout
Stevie goes for a massage while Blake
cools off on the golf course
by day three there you go
they fall back in love that's crazy I
thought divorces took like six months or
a year yeah and like the [ __ ] kinda
legal fees and all of it like it's
always ugly so they're saying that
divorce Hotel obviously is not for
everyone like you have to be a certain
type of couple where you're gonna be
damnable yes don't though to finish in
three days no but my parents got
divorced my parents got divorced and it
was like a six-month - like a one-year
thing and then my dad
like do these hidden recordings that
could bring me into brienna like my dad
I'd be like he had a secret recorder and
you have like who do you want to stay
with I didn't know I'm like a little kid
and I'm like and then you know like when
your dad just buys you McDonald's you're
like I wanna stay with you dad yeah and
then later on my mom would be like hey
how come you thought you said you want
to stay with your dad what are you
talking about no like your dad has a
recording of you oh my god not mine my
dad just that [ __ ] was easy
hug him he needs a hug he's bringing it
up a lot lately I think it's hurting I
could leave us your dad no she roasted
him like 10 minutes ago about the debt
not having a dad she's the one that
burned me what I'll take this we'll just
sell no it was just so funny cuz I had
to put it in there cuz it was you know
it was bad it was bad my was great thank
you I understand it yeah I know anyway
moving on so divorce hotels I think it's
dope no I was actually relieved like I I
think like since that happened my
relationship with my mom got so much
stronger and also the beatings stopped
so it was so [ __ ] cool cuz I got to
the point where like I can't even have a
conversation with him without getting
into a furious yelling match and I'm
getting smacked up like it got to that
point I think I was like in junior high
already like 6 or 7th grade so when
people hear like oh no that must have
been horrible I'm like nah dude it was
actually awesome like it was really good
really sad stuff why is that all I know
yeah it is happy because you know I mean
if you're happy on that yeah yeah no it
was really good I mean I don't I don't
know you know like I think the way
people imagine it is cuz like they're
not going through it so they imagine
something bad worse than what it really
is first when you said
pictured you a seven-year-old in a
onesie and like junior high smoking
cigarettes and going to parties and [ __ ]
like but that's on my mind when you said
that daddy it was like I'm like a skinny
bald kid getting into trouble and yeah
[ __ ]
but sometimes divorce and things like
this I I feel like a lot of people go oh
my god that's so bad
but then great things can come out of it
too you know like when people can't work
it out it's actually worse for kids to
witness all the damage like that
constant [ __ ] fighting and all that
there's so much negativity but then like
when there's divorce sometimes you can
breathe but also like well as long as
the Fighting's not too bad but like you
kind of see like oh if you're in a
relationship you're gonna have
disagreements so the kid knows that so
they maybe try harder in their own
relationships instead of just poof
begone worse that's it yeah in this
situation it seems like it's catered
toward rich people that are more like
they're more like I wanna do a [ __ ]
let me just get through with this really
quick that's why they're being cordial
is because they're better at controlling
their emotions and not dealing with the
problem because dealing with emotions
and like relationships or it's way
[ __ ] harder than dealing with a
business for sure cuz because you can't
work off the same system like it can't
always be like logic which they are
probably good at yeah yeah
like having to control your own
insecurities your own ego your own
problems and then having to work through
all that [ __ ] as a couple is way [ __ ]
harder so I think what they do is like
well you know what I want to focus more
on work there's gonna be easier let me
just pay for the situation I wonder if
there's like a hotel where it's more
like a marriage counseling three-day
intensive hotel
a lot of that and hopefully try with it
yeah yeah actually give it a try
rather than like just jump straight to
that like maybe they could go to that
like a week or so 33 are a couple of I
just don't understand what it's like so
it's a hotel but you just stay in
separate rooms because right from all
over the country like to go to this
fast-paced like place hotel for that
reason gotcha
it just seems like all the ingredients
to rekindle love I know the golf ball
maybe they make the beds hella lumpy
[ __ ] so you're like a little bit more
grumpy and then massage is like subpar
well they have like a bunch of random
hired attractive people voxi sexist
walking around everywhere so what a
great idea
I wonder if they sleep in separate rooms
they do they get separate rooms they can
choose to go back to the room if they
really want this is one couple that did
mention that they did have like a one
last but of course that's they're just
gonna come back together if you still
[ __ ] I don't know man that shit's so
weird I think I think the the the part
that makes it weird for me is when the
kids come into play like you you create
like life and then like just oh it's
like it's like you're responsible for
being all the time an example to what
you created you know like like being a
good leader but then like I just feel
like there there's so much weakness in
people and so much like or they don't
value it the way you do though probably
yeah
as you value that and you and for you
when there's a kid in the picture like
it's not about me anymore it's it's very
selfless yeah and they probably don't
see it like that it's so weird I just
think like people are so [ __ ] dog
[Music]
[Music]